this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years I love
audiobooks and I have to to recommend
right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite
audiobook of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding Bhairav pots which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free audiobook and a free
30-day trial is go to audible.com
forward slash Tim and you can choose one
of those two books the graveyard book
vagabonding or more than 180,000 audio
programs so that could be a book that
could be a magazine that could be a
newspaper it could be a class it's that
easy
go to audible.com forward slash Tim
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and
grab a book enjoy this episode is
brought to you by trunk club you know
I've used them and here's why especially
in the holiday season last-minute gifts
crowded airports the family you have
enough crap to worry about during the
holidays without having to think about
mixing and matching picking out buying
clothing trunk Club has your back here's
how it works
trunk Club takes the hassle out of
shopping by shipping you a trunk of
clothes that fit perfectly make you look
amazing and in this case they would
include custom picked fall and winter
styles so go to trunk club.com forward
slash Tim you answer a couple of simple
questions about your style preferences
and size and you're signed and experts
stylists they curate clothing from top
premium brands and you approve of what
you like all this is free and just like
that a trunk arrives on your doorstep
filled with hand-picked clothing that
are perfect for you try them on keep
what you like easily return what you
don't in their prepaid trunk and this is
not a subscription service super
important because I don't buy clothing
that often but I do it every once in a
while and I've used trunk club this way
you only pay for the clothes you keep
from your truck no hidden charges just
great
clothes it's the busiest most hectic
time of the year so save your brain
cells you can still look fantastic
without spending a lot of time on trying
to do that get started today and trunk
club will style you for free plus free
shipping both ways you only pay for the
clothing that you keep so check it out
from Club comm forward slash Tim again
that's Trump Club comm forward slash Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show is usually my job to
deconstruct world-class performers
whether they are say military
strategists hedge fund managers chess
prodigies athletes entertainers
screenwriters etc but this time around
the tables are turned many of you have
wanted to hear me being interviewed and
I'm a bore you to tears but this is an
attempt and in fact we have Daymond John
who's CEO and founder of FUBU which he
turned into a business with more than 6
billion in sales but it all began with a
$40 budget and no outside funding and
Daymond has a new book out called the
power of Brooke you can check out all
sorts of cool aspects and offers of this
at power of broke calm and he is an
expert interviewer and interrogator you
may also know him of course as one of
the stars of Shark Tank but we've known
each other for quite a few years and
what you're going to hear is an
interview that was then sliced and diced
and put in a synopsized form into the
book about some of my beginnings that
you may not have heard of so it's like
the 4-hour workweek this luxury
lifestyle design blah blah blah but you
oftentimes don't know about driving
around this is me that is a used minivan
that was a hand-me-down from my mom or
giving keynote presentations to
Chihuahuas to try to develop my
presentation skills because I was so
nervous to go on stage etc etc so we dig
into a lot of the advantages you can
have if you think you are at a
disadvantage
so desperation lack of funding no
background training Network how can you
take the power of broke in this case the
power of being a rope again are starting
from scratch and turn it into
a strength that's what this conversation
is about you should definitely check out
the power of Brook it has interviews
with people not only yours truly but
with the founder of Under Armour EDM
superstars people from every possible
field you can imagine about their rocky
beginnings and how they turned a lack of
resources into a strength so without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with Daymond John so what's up you got
many other sharks Daymond John and I
have the pleasure of bringing my buddy
on to talk about the power of broke and
my buddy's name is Tim Ferriss I don't
think he needs any introduction but I'm
gonna actually read a couple of points
because I do know many of the things
that Tim has done and is still doing but
I want to make sure that that I really
put it in perspective because there's so
many things so Tim of course is an
author an entrepreneur an angel investor
and also really a human guinea pig and I
think that uh Tim exercises the power of
broke weather you know when he is
looking and vetting deals or whether he
is actually physically becoming a human
guinea pig for something or he's putting
out his book and information or he's
just out there learning so I learned
from Tim a lot and I just want to
basically introduce Tim Ferriss how you
know Tim I'm great all right that's fair
thank you thanks for being here with me
so now you know the first thing I want
to talk about is basically you know when
you came out and you decided to come out
with the 4-hour workweek right you know
we all the theory of the power broke is
the fact that we don't utilize money to
accomplish this job and I don't care if
you're working at um you know what Ford
you know it's about ingenuity and it's
about thinking but it's not about the
actual dollars the dollars will come but
being creative
why would somebody give you a book deal
because I'm told that you got turned
down by 2627 alkis I got turned out by
27 banks I guess that's the lucky number
yeah what what was the challenge of the
you know getting a book the only getting
it out there well the the first problem
if you want to look at it as a problem
was it
wanted to write a book so there was an
accidental career and I had a few
students I was guest lecturing at the
time recommend that I write a book and I
got the most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard I can't write don't write anything
longer than an email I'm not gonna do it
and when the notes started coming
together from this class and a few
friends of mine were like you should
just make this a book you have all this
material that you could turn into
something I tried to put it together and
eventually got introduced to a couple of
the right people which by the way
actually gonna take a back step so the
person introduced me to my agent was
Jack Canfield who was co-creator of
Chicken Soup for the Soul
I think this is probably most relevant
to the power of Brooke the way I met him
people are always asking me how do you
meet your mentor if you sent him an
email and asked him to be your mentor
I'm like no that's not what you do
because they have enough from a job they
don't need another full-time job
especially an unpaid one haha was I just
moved to Silicon Valley years prior
didn't know anyone didn't have any money
I was driving my mom's hand-me-down
minivan which was like pot it was
horrible not good for dating and and I
decided to volunteer for a start-up
nonprofit that held event and so I
busted my ass as volunteer I kept on
taking on more responsibilities and kept
on asking for more for more for more and
eventually they were like alright well
this guy's a go-getter we don't have
many of those among the volunteers
because they think it's volunteer work
they don't have to work hard and I was
invited to one of their board meetings
and they chose me to lead the next major
event what did that mean the important
thing here was that I got to invite I
got to choose and invite the panelists
and the speakers so I invited Jack
Canfield co-creator of Chicken Soup for
the Soul 100 million plus I sold the guy
who created the pet rock co-founder of
Electronic Arts the founder of Clif Bar
all these people that I wanted to meet
right so I had no money no connections
the only thing I had was time that was
it so flash forward a few years I want I
want I want to stop right there for a
second because you know you bring up a
very valuable point you know that you
went and you wanted to be mentored or
you want to be some you know in an
environment and you know I know that you
and I and many of us mentor people but a
lot of people don't realize what's in it
for them
where everybody comes in their pitches I
need I need I need and you know then my
pitches well you mean so I need to sleep
less to help you I need to do that and
then so you know your theory was let me
go and contribute yeah let me also go
and you know I'm gonna get up before
everybody I'm gonna go to bed after
everybody and I'm gonna become a rock
star there and I'm gonna add value and
that value will then return to me right
and at the time I had to borrow that
credibility yes so in the beginning I
had no background I had no I hadn't been
on the cover of any magazines or
anything like that so I I worked with
this nonprofit that did bring in media
so they as an organization had people
from Forbes and you know whether it was
the TechCrunch of the day whatever would
show up and that's why the panelists
want Ithaca guys and so flash forward
many years later and I never bugged Jack
and ever asked him to mentor me just
every once in a while if I had a real
life decision question and it was not
frequent I would send it to him and
eventually many years later and we're
still friends but he's like you should
make this a book and before I knew it
he's like I'm introducing you to this
person this person this person this
person all right so that's how I met the
agent who was at the time a brand new
agent he was a superstar editor but a
brand new agent so he also was in a
situation where he had you know no
resources no reputation as an agent and
we went out to sell the book together
and I got turned down violently by
almost everybody and it wasn't just a
polite no thank you
this is garbage who is this idiot to
tell me how old is he again to tell me a
B and C that people were very very
offended in some cases which is still
kind of mystifying to me but that's
something you know with all those
turndowns by what you would say would be
individuals who know the world they know
the pulse and they're telling you it's
crap yeah now there's the fine line of
we are in love with our product yeah
we're - and love we're not taking
reality right in the hand yeah
was there a way that you were measuring
it going no I'm taking the pulse here or
there yeah and I know I'm one to some
because yeah we have to be realistic not
all entrepreneurs or people are gonna
get a you know for sure isn't gonna get
it Yeah right what point did you say
this is not an F it's an A or even a B
yep
what gave me confidence I think there
are two things so the first was I'd been
testing this material on live classes
for years and I always did feedback
forums and I knew what people responded
best to I knew how to hit a pulse the
people who were in a position to buy my
book were not my target audience and so
they didn't register for them yeah the
the the the they didn't have the same
pain points maybe and so but it was
demoralizing I mean 20-plus rejections
and and not mild rejections it was
really kind of tomorrow I was like and I
started to doubt myself a little bit
here and there but I believed in the
value of the content because it was the
true story of my experience of what had
worked for me and I'd written the book
well what I'd written at that point at
least basically is an email to two
friends and two very specific friends
with very specific problems and and we
had one meeting left I remember because
I went to New York flew to New York to
go to these in-person meetings with my
agent it was just like no no no no
goodbye
no and this sounds like straight out of
a movie but it's true the last meeting
was with crown and the crown is an
imprint busiest subdivision of Random
House yeah and she's thinking myself a
lawyer this is the last meeting so
hopefully I'm gonna be the most polished
right number one and we had the meeting
we had the meeting and you can kind of
feel a meeting if it's working or not
and it wasn't it wasn't working and and
so I'm sitting there and people are
getting it like intellectually they're
like okay I get it but they were they
weren't having the visceral response and
at the time there's a guy named Steve
Ross who was in charge of staying yes or
no he was the guy and he was way down at
the end is one of those kind of like
death start meetings they do it at CIA
and all these places where they bring in
like 30 people and I don't even know who
that can't remember the people's names
and and I remembered that towards the
very end Steve's like is anything else
you'd like to say before we we kind of
cut and then we can follow up with you
as one of those like don't call us we'll
call you
like lead ups and I was like oh god here
comes number 30 or whatever and I just I
tell them I said I don't half-ass
anything and this is paraphrase but it's
just like
if you look at my records whether it's
in sports whether it's in tango whether
it's an anything like I will do anything
required I will kill myself if necessary
to make this book a best-seller and it
will be a best-seller
you guys should buy it and he was just
like that's ballsy and and that's that
later I had no idea like how the
decision-making process went but then
about a year or two later word came back
to me they're like yeah does that last
thing you said it was that that was the
end of the meeting I passed out fast did
they go to you no contract or or or
let's start writing and let's start
putting it together after that you know
once they also got a very good price
right so there's a balance of factors
right but they're like alright this guy
seems crazy enough it you know or we're
managing our expectations we're not
paying a lot more this guy is a
workhorse probably right right they're
like yeah we placed bets all the time
like all right sure like this guy seems
crazy enough and it took just a couple
weeks you know within a couple weeks it
was it was time to write well that's
great you know what and in and honestly
I never heard the details that sorta but
it has all the it has all the
personality to a traditional power or
broke theme which is number one you
didn't overburden the potential mentor
who ever was number two is you know that
person and it happened with that
potential mentor as well as at the end
of this this part of life the
decision-making person said he's gonna
do it with or without me and I want to
be part of the ride yeah I think also
that as being turned down by 27
you know publishers I think that there's
a couple of things here you had proof of
concept and that's what made you believe
that you can go because you had already
tested it yeah I also think that a
couple other things there's one there's
one thing I believe if everybody loves
it you get the lowest common denominator
I believe so I think that it's that or
they're lying to you or they're lying
you know and a hard no at least better
than maybe I'm saying maybe I'll call
you back yeah right right so so I think
that all exercises exactly what I try to
tell people we share to share with
people as the power broke and then now
we
have the book yeah it's it's it's
somebody believed in you now and no oh
the other one I like the point is you
know that agent that nobody was working
with yeah that you found and you became
partners with when I found my partners
they were you know in you know my
partners who ended up help me distribute
clothes yeah they were number twenty
thirty forty in the business I noticed
that everybody likes to go to number one
in tune I want to go to number 20 who
wants to be number one yes exactly
right because if they have the
connections they have the pipeline they
just don't have the product and or the
grit of the newer position and that's
what you found so okay now all of a
sudden you are you have this book deal
that you are you really told them that
you were going to change the world and
become a best-seller which is one of the
hardest things to do especially at the
time when books were starring a plummet
they give you a deal the deal they don't
give you a lot of money and even when
they give you a lot of money they barely
do any marketing right now you have to
go out and market this book and you have
to deliver on your work what happens how
does that happen
so the I remember very very clearly it
was I get this right it was December
26th 2006 so the book was slated to come
out April and I've been thinking about
this for a while but what I realized
like you said publishers tend to put
money behind books they've already put
money into write and they hadn't put any
money into mine really and it was my job
to try to figure out how to market but I
didn't have free rein I didn't have a
full hand of options because the
publisher didn't want me meddling with a
lot of stuff they're like no no we might
do stuff with print we might do stuff
with this reminded stuff with that
and what that left me was online and
online is obviously a big category that
they keep in mind this is end of 2006
Twitter all right weird was just coming
out I was it was baby what was out at
that time so it would have been it
Google obviously you've Adwords and
things like that Facebook you had
Twitter which was very nascent myspace
was myspace was sort of yeah okay
and there were but there was kind of
word on the street that like bloggers
bloggers were interesting who are these
bloggers people yeah and so I realized
that if online is the only sandbox I can
plan I should probably figure out what
the hell blogs and bloggers are and it's
embarrassing to say it at this point but
so I went online I remember the day
after Christmas I'm like I really need
to figure this out everything I thought
I was going to do I'm not allowed to do
apparently so I searched you know most
influential bloggers and Technorati came
up at the time a few things if you know
a number of different things came up and
I saw a summit there was this some type
of uh Novus CES that's right Consumer
Electronic Show in Vegas and what to my
mind because I used to do I used to have
to sell mass data storage systems when I
graduated from school the first job I
had was like boiler room selling storage
area network so I made a lot of cold
calls and a lot of cold emails and I
realized okay Walt what is the hardest
way to get a hold of a blogger the most
crowded way is probably email and there
they're getting tons email the second
most crowded would be fun right but they
don't just put their phone on the
internet all right for the most part
unless unless Robert Scovill who ended
up being very instrumental and then the
least crowded is in person and that so I
decided that I was gonna try to track
down how do I find groups like herds of
bloggers in one place and I looked at
CES and I bought a ticket to Vegas and
I'd never went to see yes I ended up
going to I started asking around yeah
effectively like where can I meet
bloggers where could I ask bloggers
questions and they said oh you should go
to the should go to lounge
Seagate sponsoring a lounge called the
blog house H aus and it's free booze and
frequent bloggers I was like perfect I
go to this vlog house and tip for people
always be nice be nice and this is all
this this is where it's gonna get really
that becomes really crucial so I walk in
there's there's a woman who's who's
helping people get situated and sign in
and checking their wristbands and I was
that was very nice to her I didn't know
anybody and sat down and just what I
would I would sit in on conversations
and I basically just say hey guys I'm
first-time CES I don't know anything
do you mind if I just eavesdrop I would
buy a round of drinks but it's free I'll
get you some drinks and they're like
yeah okay whatever and I just did that
over and over and over again and it
turned out later you know because I was
I was kind of lost like babe in the
woods and speaking with this woman marry
him who was helping people check in and
everybody wanted at that time to talk to
this guy named Robert Scoble who was
just he was a big deal he was the guy
like if you wanted somebody to talk
about you or anything you were doing he
was the guy but everyone was on top of
him I mean everyone was just you know
clamoring to get ahold of this guy and I
felt like that was not the right way to
talk to him I didn't want to be one of
20 people trying to get his attention
and it turned out lo and behold you know
I brought this up to this woman who was
helping me check in and she was his wife
and and says she's like oh you know no
problem you can be Robert he's really
easy to talk to you no problem and she's
just like wait until they're done doing
their thing so like hang out I've
nothing else to do hang out for another
hour and a half two hours three hours
whatever was and she made the
introduction and that a very small
mention from Robert is one of the
critical things that started the entire
snowball and I took my experience at CES
because I felt like it was positive
there weren't any big results yet
because the book hadn't come out but I
was like this seems to be working
somehow like I'm getting that sixth
sense that things are starting to gel
and because I was very honest I didn't
try to impress anybody this is another
thing I didn't try to impress anybody
with what I knew about tech or anything
I would be the first person if they're
like that a Ruby on Rails maybe like I'm
sorry I'm deep in the ignorance pool
here like I'm around and what is Ruby on
Rails I'm sorry guys and it was so
uncommon that people would do that and
admit when they didn't know something
that people would then start asking me
questions what are you doing here am i
working on my first book ok what's your
book about now just let them kind of
draw it out of me
I wouldn't pitch I wouldn't go into full
pitch mode cuz that's just like it's
just like trying to go on dates you
can't just suddenly give a woman a five
minute pitch like it doesn't work like
desperation doesn't roll the jugular it
doesn't work and so I went to South by
Southwest and managed to like finagle
beg and plead and negotiate and go
through many many
for people to try to get a speaking spot
and they're like no no no and Hugh who
Hugh Forrest who run South by Southwest
Interactive is now a good friend but at
the time like he must have been so
irritated because I kept on trying kept
in trades like no no no no no and then
they had a cancellation I think like a
very last-minute cancellation they're
like okay you can go into the sponsored
room or people are gonna be like eating
and drinking like not an idea all right
like you'll be in the Adobe I think as
the Adobe such in such room and you'll
have half hour an hour and when I gave
that presentation and I and I didn't
have a place to stay all the hotels were
sold out like how all those memories are
coming back now
I stayed gonna tear up here so I stayed
at a friend's house you'll love this and
I was so nervous about giving my
presentation he had three chihuahuas all
all different personalities different
sizes and I went into the garage and the
dogs came except I was going to go get
food and I gave my presentation these
chihuahuas over and over and over again
and and of course I assumed they
couldn't understand a word I was saying
but if I was boring like if I didn't
move around
I wasn't engaging they would take off I
was like doing this kind of stuff
they're like you know do you really Tony
Robbins singing at them and keeping that
engaged then they sat there kind of
petty mesmerised I don't know whatever
he's doing it's exciting so I watch and
and I went I gave this presentation the
tech failed I remember that I had a
whole presentation and like the laptop
like the the internet connection was
dead okay guess I'm just gonna have to
wing it and but I'd rehearse so much
gave this presentation and that was just
that's that's where it took off but yeah
well where's well I think I think the
most important thing that I don't know
if everybody else is gonna learn but I
have two hot dogs and two Chihuahua song
I start doing my pictures no matter what
level we're like but I think the
valuable thing that you mentioned in the
story a couple things first of all what
you said about the bloggers is going you
know app them the normal traditional
route you know individuals who are in
the space they are approached a million
times and I have the same problem with
music artists and producers I can go
down and try to find them at a comprar
when they're getting 9,000 cards yeah
something like that you know what I did
I started trying to find a way to meet
them in clubs and hang out at the studio
because you know a music artist is not
waking up until 2 o'clock in the
afternoon because they weren't
performing mind in the studio at night
so I try to do that of course and I
think also one of the most important
things you said is be nice to everybody
yeah you know Mary Kay made a statement
years ago of course everybody's walking
around an invisible sign on them saying
make me feel important right and many
people think that this whole thing of
walking around with yeah I need to speak
to the man I that's that's not probably
gonna get you as far as speaking to the
wife of the daughter of the kids and and
many times even or shark tank
something will a product I'll have it'll
air I'll call all my big to-do guys hey
I want to do a deal with you and they'll
go yeah whatever
let them be home in the bed with their
wife watching TV and some chips and that
product then airs and she goes oh my god
I would use it my phone lights up the
next day so the the the most trusted
advisors of individuals are the people
they love and make sure you're nice and
especially even if they don't love them
and they trust them like their
secretaries or their doctors these are
the people that can say hey this is a
good guy oh that's a great girl
so I love those stories that and that
that's absolutely the most amazing thing
and I think that one of the last things
are your transparency don't walk in the
room like you know everything because
when you're talking to very seasoned
people there's a certain code and/or
language that we speak not that is
hidden but there's certain things you
would say that can pick up that we know
that you're lying
right absolutely
so now saying you got the book deal you
meet the bloggers the book you know
where does the book end up in life at
that point you know and just give us the
basically the the what grade did you get
in that book ah well you know the book
book was hard to write I still find
writing really difficult and book
launches and I constrained what I spent
also I could have spent more and I chose
not to I kept my a my mic
this is really tight I mean I was like
five to ten grand and that's mostly just
flying around trying to find people the
but part of the reason I kept it tight
is that it made my it required that my
thinking was more precise and it
required that my thinking was unorthodox
right so even if you can afford more
whether it's time money whatever it
doesn't mean you should use it because
you don't want all of that margin for
error necessarily we want to force the
hard thinking so in the book came out I
remember I was I was killing myself for
this for this book lunch and so I should
also point out that you know the the
point of the 4-hour workweek an all the
case studies in it is that you control
this currency called time and you can
allocate it to things that either give
you the most pleasure of the highest
leverage right and in this case I knew
the book was going to give me the most
leverage if executed well so I was just
killing myself you know I kind of after
doing an 80/20 analysis I'm like this is
where my time is best spent and I did I
don't think if you I'm sure if Brian and
satellite radio tours before where you
just walk in and you do like 40 radio
shows in a row it's exhausting and I was
towards the end of the day this was a
Wednesday pretty sure was a Wednesday
and I was just demolished and I got a
call from my editor and I was like yeah
hey Heather how's it gone I'm dead I'm
really beat like my brains gonna be very
helpful right now she's like well hi
there mister New York Times bestselling
author and I was like okay curse I was
just like I was like Heather please
don't [ __ ] with me right now I'm so
tired
please and she's like no you hit the
list thank you you are you're on the
extended list but you hit the list and I
was just saying and you know I just kind
of leaned back against the wall fell
down and I was like kind of sitting
there with my head in my hands and it
was like wow you know I'd wanted it but
like on some level didn't think it was
gonna happen and and so the first book
just explodes and goes ballistic
I mean goes completely nuts and hits the
New York Times list stays on the New
York Times list for for about four and a
half years unbroken every week it's
number one
I guess translated into now 40 something
odd languages and still still sits
around like 200 on Amazon now yeah and a
book the book
the books amazing and obviously that's
why I value your contribution to for
this time you know yeah um you go on
after that you go and do the for our
body
yep correct and again bang right there
now all of a sudden you know you decide
to do exactly what you do best you start
to look at the next best opportunities
where the trend and or the people are
going because you know you know as they
say you you know you want to be where
it's going to be not yeah it's at now
right you go do a deal alright and what
happens with this this book deal you go
to do yeah yeah exactly says like Wayne
Gretzky right you want you want to go to
where the puck is going to be not where
it is and I noticed a trend where with
4-hour workweek the percentage of
digital sales ebooks was about it's a
six percent in the first month or two
because the Kindle was also just
becoming a thing and then for the 4-hour
body it was about 25-30 percent and I
could just I could see where the trend
was going and where consumption was
going of printed material so I had an
opportunity to be the first major book
acquired by Amazon publishing which is
not self-publishing so Amazon was was
and did launch Amazon publishing which
would pay advances recruit authors and
compete head-to-head against the big six
you know those are the Simon the
Schuester's the Random House's and
everything and I had a chance to be the
first right and I like being first there
are a lot of risks with that you take a
lot of arrows if anything's gonna go
wrong you're gonna feel it but I just I
love doing it's one of those things
that's what gets me excited and I was
like you know like if that's a wave no
one surfed before like I want to try
that and so decided to partner with
Amazon and it was huge news went out
your time everything and I expected
there to be some blowback and expected
there to be some issues but men were
there a lot of issues Barnes and Noble
somewhat expected it boycotted the book
so no wasn't the biggest biggest guys
yeah the big the big guy like the big
guy and then a ton of other folks in the
UK Canada followed too
then the Indies followed suit and then
what I didn't expect was the big box
guys who are also afraid of Amazon for
related but different reasons
Costco Target Walmart all boycotted the
book so now you're in a situation I was
in a situation was like okay my entire
reputation the last three years of my
life and I put about three years in each
book it hinges on getting this to as
many people as possible and I have
effectively zero retail distribution
right now what and I had to do a bunch
of very unorthodox things to try to get
it out into people's hands so one and
there's there's an expression you hear
sometimes in publishing which is the
hardest place to sell a book is in a
bookstore why because there are million
other books and I I started reaching out
to other people with large retail
footprints and Panera Bread was one of
them and and it turned out at a lot of
fans at Panera and part that has a
benefit of the first book and so we did
sort of a shock and awe campaign in New
York City specifically around all the
other publishers to like fire a warning
shot and so the the book distribution
through Panera was done primarily in New
York but is for the PR benefit right
right because it wasn't planned to do
the whole thing nation and we're talking
about the 4-hour chef at this point
4-hour chef right so we're doing 4-hour
chef and we launched it with a a secret
menu also at Panera where people could
get slow car about items which means no
bread at Panera means a bread so we did
all this simultaneously I also so I had
to think about it basically going back
to square one because it's as as if I
have almost as if I have no money
because I have no retail distribution at
all so it's like no you didn't have it's
not that you didn't have any money you
were actually negative you had enemies
yeah I don't write clean even if he had
money even money I couldn't buy my way
in placement at the endcap right in
Barnes Noble what wouldn't happen right
exactly so I was actually had a deficit
okay so we did a bunch of really
interesting things we also basically the
same time I took over Panera negotiated
really well and took over a portion of
the taxi cabs in New York City to run a
trailer for the book
and simultaneous with that did something
which cost really no money at the time
got in touch with BitTorrent and
BitTorrent for the people who don't know
I mean it's a it's a peer-to-peer fire
file-sharing Network basically they
wouldn't like that description very much
but where you can find almost anything
and and they wanted to establish
themselves and this is where you have to
figure out what other people want I know
you know this there's like you can't
just be the I need I need like you said
what does what do other people want nice
I sought out people like bit tour
because they want to establish
themselves as a way for legitimate
artists or producers to spread content
to new fans and I was like I can be your
poster boy right and I will basically
even the same pitch I gave to crown
right when I sold my first book I was
like I will I will do everything I'm
going hard I'll go hard because this I
need this so I will do everything I can
to put you guys on the map with like
mainstream media is a legitimate source
of distribution so did a big partnership
with then a ton of content given away
for free email gates which means we got
email addresses for people who signed up
to get these things for free
long story short it was the the entire
torrent bundle so if you see a 4-hour
chef bundle you can still find it was
downloaded I think more than two and a
half million times and it became at the
end of the day in when we looked at at
it in retrospect like the number five I
think most downloaded torrent of the
entire year ahead of some of the biggest
musicians you've heard of and all of
these things helped drive it to you know
number one Wall Street Journal hit the
list stay there sat there for a while
and would I have sold more books if I
had full retail rollout probably would
it if forced me to be as innovative
probably not do I regret having made the
decision no and that's it and and and I
think you are the epitome and you sum it
all up I mean you know the the lessons
to take aways from there are two things
number one is you know people believe
that that after they get to a certain
stage like what if they get to that
certain stage like they're not gonna
have roadblocks and obstacles so whether
you're Steve Jobs who was fired over at
Apple or you're Bill Gates and the
government is coming after you for this
to try to
try to choke you or your donald trump
and you leverage too much of your
properties or your Daymond John and
after FUBU goes they go oh that was just
a fad people don't like baggy jeans no
it's never gonna happen again
don't think that it's ever going to stop
actually the more successful you become
you just trade off you get yeah you just
trade up exactly you just trade up the
haters right but on also what you you
also have really showed me and everybody
who's watching is at whatever level you
get you have to roll up your sleeves and
you have to dig in deep and you yourself
have to do it if you think you're gonna
Calicut it to everybody else and the
whole idea about being a boss and the
owners to sit home and do this and that
I don't believe that success is gonna
follow that so you go ahead and break
all the records and of course the book
goes off to doing really really
impressive numbers and it's still out
there and you know I just want to sum
this all up because first of all here's
where I find you amazing I find the fact
that you you you find new and viable
veins to go out there and push your
agenda as well as enrich people's lives
because if you really look at not only
how you've gotten there what you put out
is probably the most valuable thing that
we have in our lives there's only three
things that really can help us in life
or hurt us
it's and it's time it's your health and
it's your nutrition and they're all
married together and if any one of those
three fall yeah you can't be successful
right and I'm not talking about success
is necessarily going to be money yeah
you can't have a productive life as a
father and mother child you know a loved
one and or you can't have success so
first of all that's valuable and I
really urge everybody who's watching is
- please please read the books and I am
a huge fan of it I'm just gonna sum it
up with some of the other things that
Tim has done and this is going to be
very very short but uh Tim is an
investment advisor in things such as you
may have heard of them
Facebook Shopify uber Evernote angel
lists Twitter and the list goes on I
will list everything and
way that you can really check out Tim's
materials and I'm a big fan of his
thank you Tim fuh for hanging out with
me and I really did learn things I'm I'm
a student of life man oh thank you this
is great I appreciate it yeah hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that have discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite audio
book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free audiobook
and a free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash Tim and you
can choose one of those two books a
graveyard book vagabonding or more than
180,000 audio programs so that could be
a book that could be a magazine that
could be a newspaper could be a class
it's that easy go to audible.com forward
slash Tim that's audible.com forward
slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
this episode is brought to you by trunk
club you know I've used them and here's
why especially in the holiday season
last-minute gifts crowded airports the
family you have enough crap to worry
about during the holidays without having
to think about mixing and matching
picking out buying clothing truck love
has your back here's how it works
truck club takes the hassle out of
shopping by shipping you a trunk of
clothes that fit perfectly make you look
amazing and in this case they would
include custom picked fall and winter
styles so go to trunk club comm forward
slash Tim you answer a couple of simple
questions about your style preferences
and size and your side and expert
stylist they curate clothing from top
premium brands and you approve of what
you like all this is free and just like
that a trunk arrives on your doorstep
filled with hand-picked clothing that
are perfect for you try them on keep
what you like easily return what you
don't in their prepaid trunk and this is
not a subscription service super
important because I don't buy clothing
that often but I do it every once in a
while and I've used trunk club this way
you only pay for the clothes you keep
from your trunk no hidden charges just
great clothes it's the busiest most
hectic time of the year so save your
brain cells you can still look fantastic
without spending a lot of time on trying
to do that get started today and trunk
club will style you for free plus free
shipping both ways you only pay for the
clothing that you keep so check it out
from club comm forward slash Tim again
that's Trump Club comm forward slash Tim
and until next time thank you for
listening